[Musique]
souvenez vous c'était en 2001 les
français découvrent les yamakasi des
acrobates de rue qui défient la gravité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les figures pratiqué dans le
film ce sont transposés dans la vie
réelle aux clayes-sous-bois une section
parcours a vu le jour en 2011 pour
répondre à la demande
ici la pratique de ce sport urbain
rebaptisé fristel gym se passe en
intérieur dans un gymnase une chute pour
vous n'êtes pas mal quand même parce que
vous maîtrisez pas 100% de la figure je
leur ai proposé d'apprendre en toute
sécurité
des figures acrobatiques et dès lors que
la figure est acquise en intérieur
maintenant on peut le faire à
l'extérieur et il y aura à mon goût
beaucoup moins d'accidents depuis la
création de cette section la pratique de
cette discipline connaît un franc succès
au club
le nombre de licenciés est passé de cinq
adhérents la première année à une
quarantaine de pratiquants venus de
toutes les yvelines pour cette saison
2010 8
c'est notre corps c'est pas un vélo
c'est pas un équipement c'est vraiment
notre corps c'est une chute sur faute
d'accord si on doit être très rigoureux
on est très libre on apprend vraiment de
on est capable une grosse apprennent à
lire quand on lance la figure il ya une
montée d'adrénaline et dès qu'on la
rentrée compense en euros car moins une
fois les bases maîtriser pour nancy
cours de trois heures le vendredi
c'était de brûler dépasse les frontières
du gymnase jimmy pour pratiquer ce sport
dans son lieu de naissance la rue les
pratiquants à peu les traceurs utilise
le milieu urbain et la nature pour
réaliser des figures
[Musique]
on n'est pas vraiment des casse croûte
pour ça que les gens partent en ont peur
dans la rue c'est il pense qu'on se
lance comme ça et que si on se rate
c'est notre faute mais on passe beaucoup
de temps on sait on sait de quoi on est
capable on fait quand même beaucoup de
repérage avant de se lancer
et c'est une phase très importante parce
que sinon
la peur prend le dessus et lancement en
danger alors qu'on aurait peut-être été
capable de le faire c'est pour ça qu'on
fait très attention avant de se lancer
pour n'importe émouvoir mais celle ci
décrit sous bois espère désormais
atteindre une centaine d'adhérents dans
les prochaines années la structure
pourrait surfer sur la dynamique de ce
sport qui viennent d'être inscrits
officiellement dans la fédération
française de gymnastique